thanks jillian don mccarthy beauty and
lifestyle advisor was just at cosmoprof
north america for three days in las
vegas checking out the latest trends in
beauty let's see what she found for us
welcome to cosmoprof north america here
in las vegas come with me and let's
check out everything that's happening in
beauty let's go
[Music]
first up let's see what's trending in
nails
i'm here at not polish and they've got
an at-home kit as well as a professional
kit you've got to check this out i'm
here at easy tech who has great hair
styling tools i'm loving this two-in-one
volumizing hair dryer brush it's half
the size of other things to really get
that lift out of your bangs and the lift
out of the back of your hair i'm here at
eva nyc and we're talking about hair
care for some blondes and brunettes and
an amazing serum check this out what i
love about this is it's more of a cream
rather than oil
look at that shine
now for a blow dryer with infrared
that's going to boost your shine and
manageability
it's time for a little bit more hair
care and i'm here with jeremiah hi i'm
with tara rx the first death owned
haircare line in the world
and i love it that it's for
professionals and the at-home user and
he's from houston texas debra
now it's time for some skin care and i'm
here at mirabella and check this out
this is great new innovative skincare
that is a wireless rechargeable seven
color mask to help you heal and look
better
and it's got protective goggles
so for my makeup lovers i didn't forget
about you i'm at the balm cosmetics
booth and i'm loving their liquid
eyeshadows and they're all under 15
check out these colors
now it's time to go discover green
here's a great medical grade hand
sanitizer from lemon that was just
released smells amazing and you just
need a little amount goes a long way
we're also keeping it green for the kids
with you and oil
i'm at harahara wonder and what i love
about this show is the fun new packaging
for products this isn't just a cup of
coffee there's actually face cream
inside
now it's time for discover beauty where
all the new beauty brands come to
from too cool for school this is really
fun for your face it's an all-in-one egg
mellow cream what i love about it is
when you put it on your hand
it's really really really fun
if you want a long lasting lip try this
liquid lip by mtu nyc
it's what i'm wearing now and i've been
wearing all day
i'm at the mellow way booth they have
great great colors and what's so
innovative about their products this is
their primer which i'm all about when i
use my mascara
it tilts to make it nice and easy for
you to apply
this is the air cordless hair dryer this
is a beauty product that you're getting
a sneak peek at that won't even be
released until 2022 how cool is this to
be able to just blow dry your hair
and don't worry i didn't forget you guys
check these products out i'm here at
roosevelt where we've got you men
covered for everything under twenty
dollars yes they've got hair care and
skin care check it out new to roosevelt
is their skin care line but don't worry
they still have their iconic pomade and
hair care line
and lastly defining men's beauty since
2014 my johnson and co has a great new
powder for your guy
that's it for cosmoprof 2021 go to
donscorner.com to get more information
thank you don for more information visit
donscorner.com